scuffles with police as opposition
politicians lead protests against
president kai's side
he's dissolved parliament and replaced
the electoral commission in tunisia now
he wants a referendum next month to
change its constitution critics say his
changes amount to a coup at the
headquarters the electoral authority
more scuffles with police
we came as political parties and
activists to express our views but we
were attacked by the police who spread
tear gas on our faces
side has been polls and political
advertising and told international
election observers they are not welcome
the protesters don't believe the vote in
july will be free or fair they say syed
has too much power and democracy is in
danger
many of those demonstrating on saturday
spent several years in prison under
tunisia's former president
ben ali
they say they don't want to go back to
an authoritarian regime
recently said sacked 57 judges giving
himself even greater judicial power
judges from the association of
magistrates say president side could use
the law to eliminate his opposition
the president justified these dismissals
under the pretext of fighting corruption
but the fight against corruption should
not be conducted outside the law and
outside transparent procedures that give
judges the possibility to defend
themselves
these procedures allow the truth to be
unveiled and corruption to be exposed
president kai side says he's building a
third republic and cleansing tunisia of
corruption but his opponents accuse him
of corrupting democratic institutions
and reaching for absolute power and
control over the country
eliza folkman al jazeera tunis